what's going on reject nation John and I
just happened to be around we weren't
doing anything else that's the way our
lives were and found out a solo Star
Wars story another trailer just dropped
yeah this is awesome got notified from
patreon speaking a patron I'm gonna give
a pitch in the day shot to Jason
Dolan today by the way over our page
around we do full-length TV show
reactions for shows I cover attack on
Titan the flash John does Riverdale
Marvel's Runaways Atlanta together we're
doing my hero academia Jessica Jones
season 2 black lightning weekly queuing
A's and yeah a whole bunch of stuff
anyway I'm sure you guys are sick of
these self plugs but you know it's the
YouTube career now anyway let's check
out this trailer oh boy
potential Kessel runs that's all I care
about seeing is how he did that all
those parsecs gee 12 12 hours parsecs
[Music]
do something
money
[Music]
I heard every gay about you I was
wondering if it's true everything about
me is true
let's go with the mean man's face l 3
[Music]
if you come with us you're in this life
for good
all I want to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
it looks fun that was a much more
exciting trailer than the first it looks
fun it looks it looks interesting it
looks exciting it doesn't look like
necessarily necessarily like it's gonna
be anything truly like grabbed and at
this point with all the you know
behind-the-scenes drama just everyone
collectively kind of not looking forward
hugely to this I'll take fun day why not
I'm wondering what the tone of this
movie is actually going to be because I
so even though we've got two trailers I
still feel like it hasn't really been
that communicated to us yet yeah I feel
like they're going for some sense of you
know stylish intrigue but that's not
really that specific in rogue adventure
yeah and just reading up you know I I
don't even know what the studio wants
for this anymore because they seemed
like they wanted something a little more
comedic and that's not exactly what I'm
grabbing off of this aside from like
there's just always a droid that's the
comic yeah l-3 look entertaining donald
glover is probably gonna be the scene
stealer in this movie joey is a hundred
ninety years old at this point all
necessary things to understand it before
yeah the impressions i got were like
what do I like about stars I love the
cool like world and tech designs and
stuff and this looks like it's rich with
that Italy there gonna be a lot of cool
scenes and places and world building
stuff again not entirely necessary but
just a fanservice movie Woody
Harrelson's showing up again to add some
weight to another movie like this Paul
Bettany looks interesting I think I
forget his name but the main dude hole
didn't Ehrenreich yeah he looks better
that's hot but I'm at least like okay
I'm like you could be passingly amusing
for this movie sure like weirdly I think
that's kind of alright I like that the
pressure has really come off this movie
and now we all just want to have it all
right I think the reason why the tone is
being confusing to me is because this
movie is lit so dark but it's got this
humorous tone in its scenes that just
seemed like kind of confusing to me
it's such a dark looking us that it does
have an intensity to the way that
they're framing stuff and the way they
were making some of these things look
and I mean that's not out of place for
Han Solo but yeah I can't really tell
what this movie is supposed to be
feeling like and how smooth it'll be
given all this happen most would be like
a upbeat vibe I mean the cast looks good
I feel like if anything we're gonna get
more understanding into who the hell
Chewie is that's gonna be the big thing
yeah it looks like a fun serviceable
time yeah it's a cool fun time and
honestly at this point after the big
split that last Jedi had I can't co4
just could enjoy yeah Star Wars where
the pressures off and we can just go
have a lockout going it wasn't necessary
but we had a good time and hey I'm gonna
give a page from the day shout out for
no love Jason Dolan who is one of the
screenwriters of the vanishing ascending
Hall which stars Logan Lerman it was a
really good film who was considered to
play Han Solo fascinating yeah fast
I read Wikipedia before he actually sent
us over this photo here oh look at this
guy it's young Jason Dolan dreaming
about Hans origin story yeah yeah he
wanted to be on solo girl and knowing
Jason Dolan today you are like a han
Solo yeah you got the charm you're
better you should have been cast because
you have this stylish rogue personality
that this movie needed dude a stalker
you're witty you're clever you can
outsmart people you can make a Kessel
run in like easily eight or nine parsecs
Oh easily yeah like now I got a to do to
support this statement and yes and with
it is understand what a parsec is Jason
Dolan thank you so much for supporting
our page from page this guy's working on
a vampire movie right now and he's
actually gonna let me read the script
for it not me decided to see that not
this guy I know it had the same email we
shared I can't wait to take a look at it
dude and you have been so kind of
friendly hooked us up with so much stuff
yeah we love you buddy
happy to have you here all right guys
well you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell so
in the subscription but it means
something and check us out on patreon
for all the things we said earlier in
this video show you out in the next
train
good day